I am really grateful to be back here as
Ian said I was University associate
university chaplain here for 12 years
and an intern before that so this Chapel
has been my spiritual home probably of
more than any place in my life I was
ordained here in this space let me think
I can't do the math but october twenty
four 1993 so it's been a while both our
boys spent their earliest years here
Connor who is now ten was baby Jesus
here his first Christmas I have
participated in memorial services and
weddings and baptisms and more sunday
mornings than I can count I am grateful
to Ian for inviting me and Sharon and
Calista and others in the chaplains
office for welcoming me back so warmly
on friday and to you all many of whom
are old friends and many I have not met
as the community has continued to grow
but on behalf of myself and my partner
mimi and our boys we are so glad to be
here I feel at home here in this space
like no other even though it is no
longer my everyday home it is the home
of my heart and of shared history and of
the current welcome and community so I
thank you and now let us pray may the
words of my mouth and the meditations of
all our hearts be acceptable in your
sight o God our rock and our Redeemer
amen one of my most precious memories
from this space is from sep tember of
1997 madeleine l'engle a beloved
connecticut author she wrote a wrinkle
in time for those of you who know that
book or and may or may not recognize her
name she spoke hear that sep tember she
was I think in her mid 70s at that time
vital and energetic with piercing eyes
but also needing to sit for her talk so
we brought up a wing chair from the
Levitt room and plopped her down in the
chair right there
I glimpsed what it might have been like
to be one of Jesus disciples to want to
sit at the feet of a teacher and just
listen and learn Madeleine spoke and
then she answered questions well she
kind of answered questions somewhat like
Jesus she used the questions to go where
she wanted to go never directly hitting
the question but giving us so much more
than we could have possibly thought to
ask kind of like Jesus that way what I
remember most from that evening was a
story that she shared a rabbi story she
called it rabbi said the student why in
Deuteronomy does it say we should write
the words of God on our hearts rather
than in our hearts replied the rabbi we
are not ready to have the words of God
in our hearts but if we write them on
our hearts when our hearts break they
will fall in mammal and linkle shared
that story on a Thursday evening and on
Friday morning Mimi flew to Tennessee to
be with her mother in her last days I
stayed through Sunday when I preached on
this rabbi story and then joined her her
mother died about 10 days later and
Mimi's heart broke as well as her
sisters and her dad and the words of God
in Scripture and song and poetry did
indeed fall into the broken hearts that
story has stayed with us and in all
these years many beloved words of God
continue to be written on our hearts and
in the hearts of our families and
friends they are written waiting to fall
in again when we need them
today's Gospel though doesn't seem to be
one of those stories that I would write
on my heart to comfort me in brokenness
it's not one of the scriptures that a
preacher longs to be assigned either Ian
sent me these texts long ago and I
looked quickly and thought yeah that's
good that's fine I can do the lectionary
but lo and behold it is not on the top
of my list to preach about the Sadducees
but there it is waiting for us waiting
for me this morning and I haven't been
able to avoid it so let's look at it
again a little bit this is the story of
the Sadducees trying to trick Jesus
testing his theology his understanding
of Torah his belief and his wits the
Sadducees don't believe in resurrection
so they come up with an extreme
situation to point out just how
ludicrous the idea of Resurrection is
and they're tricky they pick a situation
where to obey Jewish laws makes the idea
of Resurrection seem crazy a man marries
a woman and then he dies without having
children so according to Moses in the
Torah if a man dies leaving his widow
childless that man's brother must marry
her to provide children as through his
brother but the Sadducees aren't content
with just two brothers in this story two
marriages no no no they create a
scenario of seven brothers and that poor
woman who doesn't even seem to exist in
this story that's an aside though so in
the story all the brothers die Jesus who
will she be married to in the
resurrection well Jesus now what are you
gonna do an in typical Jesus fashion he
answers the question in a way that
points out the failings of the Sadducees
and also upholds the law essentially he
says marriages of this world and the
resurrection is totally different
there's no marrying them so it's not an
issue he takes on the content the
surface level the question and answers
it and then he continues and uses Moses
himself to support the idea of the
resurrection Moses says that God speaks
of being the God of Abraham the god of
Isaac the God of Jacob and God is the
god of the living not the dead some of
them get it and acknowledge that Jesus
has spoken well and all of them learn
their lesson and don't question him
again he puts them in their place and it
is a good story it shows us Jesus great
ability to not get tripped up by the
trick and then in the midst of the
rhetoric there really is a deep truth
about what happens when we die a deeper
truth is embedded in what appears to be
the surface level of the content what's
simply the vehicle for the trick there
is a deeper truth about life and death
and everlasting life and that brings me
to why it is that I haven't been able to
just set aside this text and focus on
one of the other texts some of you I
have known for many years and some of
you met my parents along the way as they
attended my ordination here as they came
for our wedding and later for the births
of Connor and Dylan were just to visit
and some of you knew that my mother had
Alzheimer's disease for many years for
more than five years perhaps even before
we left New Haven for Baltimore mom
didn't know us certainly not by name
sometimes not at all and for the last
three years or so she hasn't spoken
coherent sentences or even words we
didn't tell her when my father died
because we knew she wouldn't be able to
understand and we couldn't bear to tell
her over and over again this September
my mother had a stroke and she died in
mid-october not quite a month ago my
sister and brother and I were able to be
with her
with each other a lot during that last
month and I so experienced God's grace
as I found myself longing to be with her
as I knew the time together would was
drawing to a close it was a good month
for us and she died surrounded by our
laughter and our stories and our love
and Connor and Dylan have each in their
own ways helped me in these days and
weeks Connor who's 10 has cried with me
acknowledging the depth of my pain Dylan
has hugged me and held me when I cried
and then came a day two weeks ago at two
weeks after her death a day that also
was my father's birthday and because I
wasn't smart enough to notice that was
happening at the same time it was a hard
day and when I talked to me me and the
boys about it Dylan said you know where
nana is right now she's in heaven in the
kitchen making something special for
grand daddy's birthday he's so sure so
concrete he actually pictures both his
grandmother's Nana whom he knew and
grandma Jack who died before he was born
talking and cooking together he even
looks forward to when he's going to be
with them because he's sure he is
certain and he is literal he's eight
Dylan's literalness might appeal to the
Sadducees you can hear them jump on
board yeah well bad wife of that man be
cooking for her husband oh wait which
husband the second the fifth the seventh
and yet the Sadducees are so different
from Dylan because they use the literal
understanding of the Resurrection to try
and trick Jesus like so many of us they
see the logical obvious flaws and the
reasoning if there's a resurrection
whose wife's but will she be or how will
a child who has died recognized a parent
who dies 50 years later or how can there
be room for everybody how will people
find each other how will I find all the
people I know who don't know each other
and how
can we all be together if we don't know
each other and on and on if how what
about whose wife will she be anyway the
problems are obvious right the
shortfalls in thinking of heaven of
eternal life of the resurrection they're
obvious but for a child the problems
aren't obvious they don't matter many
children can just suspend disbelief and
see a truth that we mature ones are too
smart to notice the truth that Dylan
knows about life after death is a
certainty that those we love still are
he knows a truth that his nana is no
longer bound by Alzheimer's disease he
knows Ruth that her love for her husband
of more than 50 years still lives the
details may be literal and concrete as
befits an eight-year-old but the
underlying truth of love and wholeness
rings through Jesus held children before
his followers reminding them to be like
the child not to be literal but to be
open to be able to see truth beyond the
literal Jesus might say to Dylan you're
right nana's now able to love granddaddy
again Paul wrote to the Corinthians that
when he was a child he thought like a
child he spoke like a child and when he
became a man he thought like a man
perhaps the combination is what we
should seek for ourselves the ability to
be as open and true as a child while
freed from the literal details as adults
I'd like to finish with Madeleine
L'Engle again who along with my mother
taught me the most about life and death
about grief and about resurrection I
want to share some words taken from a
1990 interview reflecting on her first
experience with the death of someone
beloved her uncle and this will sound
familiar to some of you who have read
those early books about Meg and Calvin
and Charles Wallace I lost his name so
Madeleine L'Engle didn't feel she could
could ask her parents in the midst of
their own grief to talk about it and
explain it to her and here's what she
said so at age eight i postulated a
planet on which no one had any eyes of
course they would compensate perfectly
well but if one of us came from our
planet to that planet where no one had
any eyes and tried to describe a sunset
or a daffodil blooming through the snow
or a human face with a loving smile it
could not be done so age eight Madeleine
continues i postulated that when we die
we get something just as magnificent as
sight but just as no one from our planet
could describe site to someone on that
sightless planet so no one can describe
for us the wonders that God has waiting
for us when we die she continues I still
think that's pretty good theology we're
all good theologians when were eight we
tend to go downhill rapidly after that
there are words from both our sons at
ages eight and ten good theologians that
are truly the words of God written on my
heart the words from Dylan that evoke a
picture of Nana freed from Alzheimer's
loving my father the words of comfort
from Connor acknowledging how hard it is
for me to have lost both parents there
are words of hymns I love to tell the
story we each have our own words
on our hearts God's words come and many
different voices and indeed when they
are written on our hearts when our
hearts break God's words do fall in and
we can know even in the broken hearted
pneus of grief we can know with an
eight-year-old certainty that love lives
that wholeness is restored that there is
resurrection and life I know that my
Redeemer liveth thanks be to God amen